[Music]
a monarch walking freely amongst his
loyal subjects
thailand's king mahavajar along khan
greeting the people at a walkabout last
year
for a man who'd spent much of his early
reign outside thailand
it was part of a new engagement to bring
him closer to his people
for ordinary ties it's part of a
familiar routine
i've been taught to love the king since
i was young i grew up with phrases like
long live the king or i love the king
i grew up watching news about the
monarchy's household i learned about the
institution in school
people around me loved the king but then
i wondered why do we love the king
benja now rejects many of the official
histories she was taught as a child
as do other young thais who are calling
for reforms
protesters have taken to the streets
demanding the royal household be more
transparent
and accountable for many ties it marked
a huge change
ideas that were only discussed in
private are now being talked about in
public
but when protesters moved against the
crown property bureau
the office that manages the king's
enormous wealth
they found the streets blocked with
shipping containers
when they moved towards the palace they
were met with tear gas and rubber
bullets
protest leaders have been arrested and
charged with less majesty
the offense of insulting the monarchy
that comes with a lengthy jail term
since then the protests have largely
died out
that say pro-monarchists is evidence
that most thai people
have seen through the protests as an
attack on the institution
the protesters want to abolish not
reform
don't forget the demands that they've
been asking for are deliberately aiming
to bring down the monarchy
not to help improve the institution so
it's not surprising that not many people
come out to support them
on the occasion of the king's 69th
birthday there's unlikely to be much
pomp
or ceremony this year with cobit
restrictions in place
official celebrations of the king's
birthday are likely to be very muted
but many people think once those
restrictions are lifted
protesters calling for reform of the
monarchy
could hit the streets once again in
recent months the king has stayed out of
the public eye
when he's been seen he's relied on the
queen for support
and despite his position of power he
appears to be a monarch
unsure of his relationship with his
subjects
tony chang al jazeera bangkok